white people y'all don't even know how
funny y'all are
y'all chuckle a minute you don't say hey
i got that against you i just think
y'all funny people just the way y'all
walk crack me the [ __ ] up
you know just be all tight and [ __ ]
how's it going jumping yo
steve steve hey bob yeah
[Applause]
brothers we do everything with river
you're saying brother be strolling
hey
you could talk to a brother men stride
he won't miss a step
hey leroy yeah what's up man
try that with somebody white tom well
what what
what damn match i'm concentrating one
two one two
[Applause]
i like to smoke weed and watch national
geographic
because i like the nature channel like i
want to go to africa one day going to
safari
see the animals in their natural habitat
but the difference between us and y'all
is we stay in the truck
white people y'all got some [ __ ] called
up close and personal
like it's just amazing too because
that's what black people we just know
certain [ __ ]
you know like white people that's why i
study all nvr i'm envious to y'all y'all
a race y'all do whatever the [ __ ] you
don't want to do y'all you know y'all
are free
you're only only racing people that
could look at a wild lion and go
i can be friends with that
that's why y'all are always on when
animals attack you will never see black
people
or when animals attack you might see us
on when cops attack
but you will never see us on an animal's
attack
y'all would do [ __ ] like tranquilize a
lion and hold that [ __ ] tail
he'd wake up
and that'd be heavy [ __ ] to y'all y'all
be in the camera
[Music]
well my partner bob and i
we've been tracking this particular
beast for quite some time
her name is utulu she's six months old
we just shot her with five cc's of tetra
coeur d'alene darts
when she gets up she's gonna be [ __ ]
pissed
oh my god bob do you feel your heart
pounding this is amazing
oh my god she's getting a plow oh she
molded me what an experience
the africans don't be out there [ __ ]
with the lions they ask them mr matumbo
why you don't play with the lion i'm not
[ __ ] with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] him and [ __ ] you that [ __ ] is not
in the brochure i'm not doing that [ __ ]
when my shift is over i want to go home
to my children mangulu mangala and
i can't do it [ __ ] with that when the
[ __ ] you're out you better come i will
leave you in the car
it's rules
ain't no african people here is it
are you african dog my bad i want to
piss you off and you [ __ ]
i don't know what it is i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on
but i think white women started it
oh it's the worst
the [ __ ] worst that's all they do is
[ __ ] mother and complain i had no idea
how difficult it was to be a white woman
in the united states of america
evidently it's it's really difficult
yeah they're always bitching do you have
any idea what it's like to be me
well i imagine it would be slightly less
awesome than my life
what happened to you today sweetheart
huh did they not chill your rose
you know was the trolley not running
down at the mall what
happened no it's unreal i'm really
[ __ ] annoyed how white women have the
[ __ ] balls
to throw my white privilege in my face
you know
start to separate themselves from these
white males with their white male
privilege it's like [ __ ]
you're sitting in the jacuzzi with me
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah put your [ __ ] whining
look right out of the gate all right if
you're [ __ ] if you live in some honey
boo boo lifestyle
on the appalachian trail you know your
uncle just banged you in the dirt
all right i can listen to you
no one of my fantasies is i want to
drive by like a woman's rally
and just say the most sexist [ __ ] i can
think of
just to watch them lose their minds and
i'll just drive by real slow like yeah
why don't you get back in the kitchen
where you belong
just to look in the rearview mirror
watching them
flipping out in the road spinning around
like leather face at the end of texas
chainsaw massacre like
[Applause]
i could listen to that [ __ ] all night
dude remember frank's last week
it's [ __ ] smashed man
and catalogs everything they drink two
shots of jaeger
kill four bong hits men
[Applause]
beer cheeseburger
that [ __ ] is great the only bad part is
you cannot
pass out around white people
every time white dudes pass out around
each other they always do some
borderline
gay [ __ ] when the guy's asleep
frank fell asleep so he like stuck a
carrot in his ass and
put shaving cream on his balls like why
a [ __ ] why do you do that to a
friend of yours he trusted you enough
to sleep around you're gonna put a
carrot in his ass that is that nice
[Applause]
i tell you right now if i put a carrot
in a black dude that [ __ ] will kill you
when he wakes up for some [ __ ] like that
that is an automatic death sentence on
the street
it's a wrap for you i'm gonna kill that
[ __ ]
i thought y'all was friends baby what
happened
i fell asleep this house right we was
drinking and i fell asleep to this house
and and while i was sleeping right
i'm just gonna kill that [ __ ]
all right that's all you need to know
[ __ ] carrots congratulations to you
my friend look at that white woman
you're with god
damn
[Applause]
[ __ ] behind you going yeah son i'm with
my girl but
yo for real that white woman's amazing
isn't she telling the truth
he's with his black girl for like no oh
no but that she's high level
that's a high level white woman right
there that white woman is that is
man oh man oh man
black women get mad at that but that is
top shelf white woman right there
[Applause]
you know how you can tell how pretty a
white woman is
the value you look at her and then you
wonder how long they would look for
she was missing
[Applause]
come on take a look take a look look at
that [ __ ]
[Applause]
i saw you look mad sweetie how long if
you was missing how long do you think
they were
how long did they do exactly she don't
even she went
you know the deal i ain't saying nothing
wrong white woman's life is valuable
what's his name you're in uh vandersloot
right we find out he was a serial killer
man he kills women that's what he do he
do it well
you know what i mean we know the girl
that he that he you know supposedly had
uh what's girl in aruba natalie holloway
right but the one he just killed a girl
in peru what's her name um
exactly
look up as you said now you said natalie
natalie
holloway that angel
y'all said that like family feud all
right name a white girl been missing for
five years in the river
nearly highway survey
[Applause]
name a peruvian girl that was killed
yesterday
what is that big head third world
peruvian bitch's name
it has to be yotis or something goofy
don't get mad at yourself i gave it to
you you saw how fast you said natalie
holloway
diana ross right here said she knew her
name
that white guy with natalie holloway
man you caught yourself uh whoa
god bless you man that is high level
right then don't be ashamed of it
gorgeous
she's mad as hell [ __ ] that white [ __ ]
you know come on
come on ain't nobody looking for you
i might look for you but the news ain't
you
you think fox is reporting your mission
let's be honest
nancy grace she leads story on nancy
grace
for the next six months
i look at her because she's mad as hell
black we don't like that [ __ ] but it is
what it is let's be
i'm gonna be like that let's just let's
be honest
that little girl that went missing um
she was sailing
little girl was saying i forgot damn it
but she was she went sailing went
missing
in the indian ocean okay and
they spent good lord
her mass broken she was floating around
and she gave out her little signal her
beacon
they looked for they spent 500 000 like
tax money to search for her
now that's my daughter i want that to
happen too but but
if you go sailing
let's be honest how long you think that
they gonna spend five come on
remember hey remember football players
in miami went missing
they went sailing they looked for them
for eight
minutes maybe they just sent somebody at
the edge of the beach
i don't i don't see him
we have to call off the search because
there's too much sun
the sun the conditions are abnormally
difficult
if i go sailing i'm taking a white baby
on a keychain with me
if my boat go down they gonna find me
i'm gonna have it hook right to the side
of my belt
and i'm gonna dress the baby real white
too i'ma put sweatpants on it and
a pair of ugg boots and i'm gonna
take a picture